en este vídeo hablaremos un poco sobre
los lípidos muchas veces los lípidos son
fuertemente asociados con grasas y eso
no es incorrecto las grasas son lípidos
pero no todos los lípidos son grasas una
mejor asociación para los lípidos son
una clase de moléculas que generalmente
encontramos en los sistemas biológicos y
que no se disuelven fácilmente en agua
no son tan solo bles en agua no he dicho
que sean completamente hidrofóbicos es
decir que no se sienten atraídos por el
agua porque existen algunos lípidos que
tienen partes que son hidrofóbicas que
tratan de alejarse del agua pero también
otras partes que son hidrofílicas les
gusta el agua se sienten atraídas por
las moléculas de agua ahora hablando de
los papeles que juegan en el cuerpo los
lípidos juegan un papel importante en el
almacenamiento de energía siempre que
miro hacia abajo
pienso en toda esa energía que se
encuentra cubriendo mi abdomen también
pueden estar involucrados en las
realización en futuros vídeos
estudiaremos las hormonas que son
moléculas que ayudan a transmitir una
señal de una parte del cuerpo a otra y
muchas de esas hormonas son lípidos los
lípidos también están involucrados en
las membranas muchas veces hablaremos de
membranas celulares y de cómo se forman
junto con los fosfolípidos más adelante
veremos que en particular los
fosfolípidos tienen una terminal que
quiere alejarse del agua mientras que la
otra se siente atraída por el agua y eso
es lo que los hace buenos para las
membranas bien regresando a las grasas
les quiero mostrar cómo se ven algunas
moléculas de lípidos aquí tenemos el
ejemplo de una molécula de grasa la
estructura general que tenemos son estos
tres ácidos grasos aquí tenemos un ácido
graso dos ácidos grasos y tres ácidos
grasos y están conectados a un glicerol
no se preocupen mucho por todas estas
palabras las estudiaremos más cuando
lleguen a una
de química orgánica solo se las he
mencionado porque de ahí viene la
palabra triglicéridos tri por los tres
ácidos grasos y glicerina por el
glicerol un triglicéridos es otra forma
de llamar a la grasa pero que es lo que
hace que un triglicéridos no sea tan
soluble en agua bueno observen estas
largas cadenas de hidrocarburos aquí
tenemos un montón de carbonos e
hidrógeno y recuerden que las cosas que
son solubles en agua generalmente son
moléculas polares tienen una carga
parcial positiva de un lado y una carga
parcial negativa en el otro o incluso
pueden ser cargas completas cuando
analizamos estas cadenas de
hidrocarburos podemos ver que
generalmente no tienen cargas parciales
en un lado o en el otro por lo tanto no
son tan solo bles en agua otras palabras
que seguramente han escuchado en
relación con las grasas son grasas
saturadas o grasas insaturadas y eso se
refiere a lo que está pasando en estas
cadenas de
bours si el carbono está unido a tantos
hidrógenos como puede entonces estamos
hablando de una grasa saturada está
saturada con hidrógenos pero si no está
unido a tantos porque se une a otro
carbono con un doble enlace en lugar de
uno simple entonces decimos que es una
grasa insaturada en otro vídeo
hablaremos de los problemas de salud
relacionados con las grasas saturadas y
las insaturadas muchas veces en la
cultura popular las grasas tienen una
mala reputación porque todos queremos
lucir un buen cuerpo pero es muy
importante darnos cuenta de que sin las
grasas podemos morir muchas vitaminas
que no son tan solo bles en agua lo que
de hecho las convierte en lípidos
necesitan grasa para poder ser
absorbidas adecuadamente en el cuerpo
ahora como les mencioné no todos los
lípidos son grasas aquí tenemos otros
ejemplos de lípidos no entraré en muchos
detalles sobre su estructura molecular
pero aquí podemos ver algo muy similar
todos
tienen largas cadenas de hidrocarburos
que no son solubles en agua estas partes
podrían ser hidrofóbicas pero lo más
interesante especialmente de esta sting
o mielina que se encuentra en la vaina
de mielina que ayuda a aislar
eléctricamente a las neuronas y también
está involucrada con las membranas es
que constituye una parte importante de
los fosfolípidos en las membranas la
sting o mielina tiene una parte que es
hidrofílica y como veremos más adelante
eso es lo que hace que estas moléculas
sean fosfolípidos este es un skin o
fosfolípido y son muy buenos para las
estructuras de las membranas porque la
parte que es atraída al agua puede estar
por fuera y la parte que no se siente
atraída por el agua puede estar por
dentro así se van formando las membranas
en un corte transversal se ven así las
partes circulares o cabezas son las que
se sienten atraídas por el agua mientras
que las colas corresponden a las cadenas
hidrofóbicas que se
alejar del agua y de hecho así es como
se ven las membranas celulares si las
observamos con un gran acercamiento
vamos a dejarlo hasta aquí entre los
lípidos los carbohidratos las proteínas
y los ácidos nucleicos hemos cubierto la
mayoría de las macromoléculas que verán
en los sistemas biológicos pero qué es
lo que las hace macromoléculas bueno
recuerden que se componen de muchísimos
átomos no son moléculas pequeñas nos
vemos en otro vídeo